[Music]  you know  [Music]  thank you  thank you  [Music]  welcome to the this is  [Applause]  [Music]  hello  everybody here for the interview  metal what do you drive  I got the jet bike they're ready to see  you Mr grew oh good great  [Music]  here we go  [Music]  distinguished villains my name is Crow  I feel like I'm talking too loud even  though our product  doesn't require this kind of volume  you seriously think a puny little child  can be a villain yes I am pretty  despicable you don't want to cross me  back without the evil to impress me  [Music]  also take the stone back to the lair  I'll distract them  handle this  this is the biggest day of my life this  game just stole something from your  walls villains in the world  a super villain  now all I need is Otto where is Otto  are you pulling on my legs right now  Otto where's the stone oh big Astoria  poor college  foreign  [Music]  foreign